con la ofensiva no cránea atascada y la
amenaza de un Sabotaje ucraniano aquí en
Moscú era el día de la Victoria más
difícil para el presidente Ruso y sin
embargo hemos visto al Vladimir Putin de
siempre ha dicho que es el mundo
occidente el que está en contra de Rusia
que ha juntado a toda la Escoria nazi
según sus propias palabras para afectar
a la seguridad del país ha lamentado
también como ha hecho otros años que el
mundo ha olvidado las lecciones de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial y que no agradece
lo suficiente a la unión soviética y a
Rusia su país heredero lo que hicieron
para liberar a Europa del nazismo esta
vez en un tono todavía más patriótico
que de costumbres se ha dirigido a los
soldados que están ahora mismo
combatiendo en ucranela se ha dicho que
el destino de Rusia como país depende
ahora mismo de lo que ellos hagan en el
frente